[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه
الامير محمد بن سلمان يختتم زيارته الى 25
عقد استثماريا بنحو 30 مليار دولار
مصادر الدبلوماسيه تكشف للعربيه قرار
لوكاله الطاقه يلمح لاحاله ايران لمجلس
الامن
رابعه ايضا
تمشين ملتقى الاستثمار في القسيمه مئات
الفرص والمشاريع التنمويه بقيمه تتجاوز
مليارين
وضمن موسم الرياضه الرابعه تتجول في مدينه
السعاده انشطه حركيه وتكنولوجيه للاطفال
زياره مليئه بالصفقات والاستثمارات
يختتمها ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى كوريا الجنوبيه
25 عقدا ومذكره تفاهم بقيمه 29 مليار
دولار اوبريت بين السعوديه وكوريا
الجنوبيه في مختلف المجالات الصناعيه
والاستثماريه خلال الزياره شركه ارامكو
السعوديه اعلنت عن الاستثمار الاكبر لها
في كوريا الجنوبيه مشروع شاهين من خلال
شركات اس اوه الى التابعه لها وبقيمه تقدر
بسبعه مليارات دولار ولي العهد السعودي
ذكر ان السعوديه تتطلع الى رفع وتيره
التنسيق الاستثماري والتعزيز الشراك بين
القطاع العام والخاص مع كوريا الجنوبيه
وتحقيق الاستفاده الكامله من الفرص
التجاريه والاستثماريه الواحده
كبير منجزات اللجان المشتركه بين بلدينا
والطلع يرفع وتيره التنسيق الاستثماري
وتعزيز الشراكه بالقطاعين العامه الخاص
ونؤكد على اهميه الاستفاده من فرص
التجاريه واستثماريه الواعده والمتاحه
للتعاون بين بلدنا ونشيد في هذا السياق
بالنمو الايجابي في السنوات الماضيه
المعدلات التبادل التجاري بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وكوريا
الاستثمار السعودي خالد الفالح على اهميه
الشراكه بين المملكه وكوريا الجنوبيه
مشيرا الى انها تعد من اهم الشركات على
مستوى العالم
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه وكوريا علاقه
متميزه
من افضل الشركات على مستوى العالم اذا اذا
ممكن اقول فيها تكامل قوي المملكه لعب
الدور كبير في نهضه كوريا الحديثه بعد
الحرب الكوريه في خمسينات القرن الماضي
من ناحيه توفير الطاقه اللي نهضت وساهمت
في النهضه الكوريه وفي نفس الوقت الكل
يعرف ان الشركات الكوريه اااه كان لها دور
كبير والموارد البشريه الكوريه كان لها
دور كبير في بناء البنيه التحتيه والشراكه
في بناء الاقتصاد السعودي الحديث
عن شركه اس اويل تعد من اهم استثمارات
شركه ارامكو السعوديه في الخارج مشيرا الى
ان قيمه مشروع شاهين يصل الى سبعه مليار
دولار
شركه السويد من اهم استثمارات شركه ارامكو
السعوديه خارج المملكه الان بتنتقل من
توفير الوقود والطاقه لكوريا واسيا من
خلال هذا الموقع الى بتسارع كثير الى
انتاج المواد البتروكيماويه فا هو بيكون
في كراكر وبكون فيه صناعات متقدمه
للبتروكيماويات وبيكون في طبعا
خفض
للكربون فهو يعني مشروع مثالي قيمته همم
يعني بين سته وسبعه مليار دولار واليوم
وقعت ارامكو عقود ال همم
الانشاء وانا اعتقد انه مشروع يستحق
الاشاده به
من العاصمه الكوريه سول ينضم الينا المفضل
العربيه ميسون ويهضوا عقيل ابو 50 مرحبا
بكم
اترك لكم المساحه ميسون وعقيل الحديث عن
ابرز المشاهدات لهذه الزياره لولي العهد
السعودي لكوريا الجنوبيه
وكذلك ابرز الصفقات من اتفاقيات ومذكرات
تفاهم ايضا تم التوقيع والاتفاق عليها بين
الجانبين تفضل
فيها عقيل سنتحدث معه لانه اتفاقيه جدا
مهمه يعني اكثر من 26 اتفاقيه تمت خلال
هذه الزياره سنتحدث الان عقيل عن اهميه
هذه الاتفاقيات وخاصه بانه نحن نتحدث عن
مليارات
26 اتفاقيه بتكلفه حوالي تصل الى 30 مليار
دولار ميسون الصفه العامه التي تجمع
الاتفاقيات هذه كلها تقريبا انها همم
اتفاقيات تدعم توجهه الرؤيه في تنويع
مصادر الدخل في السعوديه همم وزير
الاستثمار السعودي خالد الفلاح عندما تحدث
للمستثمرين او للشركات الكوريه همم اليوم
هو 11 شركات للاستثمار في مجالات جديده في
السوق السعوديه الطاقه المتجدده يعني هذا
هو السؤال همم
عقيل هل هذا يكرس بانه السعوديه لم تعد
همم يعني تعتمد فقط على النفط وانما الان
هناك تحول الى اقتصاد جديد وصناعه جديده
في الطريق
لهذا التحول في في اقتصادها وتنويع مصادر
همم مصادر الدخل همم عبر احلال قطعه جديده
مثل الطاقه المتجدده عبر توسيع نطاق
الصناعات همم داخل السعوديه سمعنا قبل همم
[موسيقى]
صناعه للسيارات الكهربائيه قبل هيك كان في
همم حديث عن مصنع اخر لشركه لوسيد في حديث
عن الهيدروجين الاخضر مع اقوى باور
الهيدروجين الازرق مع صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه
كل هذه كل هذه الاستثمارات
ااا تتوافق مع توجه اا الرؤيه لخلق صناعات
جديده وتنويع مصادر الدخل في السعوديه
نريد ان
نتحدث ايضا ونشارك المشاهدين بانهم هذه
الزياره لها ان اهميتها الاقتصاديه ولكن
ايضا هناك علاقات همم اخرى بالاضافه الى
العلاقه المتينه الاقتصاديه ايضا العلاقه
الامنيه العلاقه السياسيه وديبلوماسيه همم
مثلا يعني حتى اليوم ولي العهد تحدث بانه
همم اكدوا على الشراكه مثلا بموضوع همم
الامن والسلم الدوليين ايضا تم الحديث عن
التعاون في الدفاعات همم
الصناعيه ايضا موضوع همم المشاريع النوويه
الصغيره همم دائما هذه العلاقه بين
البلدين كانت تربطها مصالح
ليست فقط مثلا اقتصاديه او امنيه او
سياسيه على حد سواء وانما كلها مجتمعه
واظن هذا ما الذي يميز هذه العلاقه بين
الدولتين
ميسون اذا كنت تتذكرين في عام 2000 17 كان
في
اختيار او تحالف ما بين السعوديه وكوريا
بموجبه كوريا همم اصبحت شريك استراتيجي
للسعوديه
لتحقيق مستهدفات رؤيه 20 30 همم كان هناك
زياره لولي العهد السعودي عام 2019 همم
الى كوريا اعطى الدفعه كبيره لوتيره
التعاون واللي عدد المشاريع همم الكوريه
في السعوديه والمشاريع السعوديه في في
كوريا هذه الزيارات هي الزياره الثانيه
ايضا اعطت همم دفعه كبيره للتعاون
نريد ان نذكر ايضا
عقيل هذه السنه هي مرور ذكرى 60 عاما على
اقامه هذه العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
السعوديه وبين كوريا الجنوبيه
والعديد من الاشخاص لا يعلمون بانه في
السبعينيات عقيل وفي ثمانيات كان هناك اا
اعمال كوريه جنوبيه في السعوديه ساهموا في
بناء الجسور لا ادري اذا كان لديك معلومات
بعد او فمثلا امنا عن هذا الامر خصوصا
الصحيح همم الكوريين ساهموا في همم عمليات
الانشاء البنيه التحتيه في السعوديه وفي
دول الخليج في السبعينات
والثمانينات من بعد هذه همم السنوات كانوا
للسعوديه مثل ما تحدث وزير الاستثمار
السعودي همم اليوم كان السعوديه تدور كبير
في بناء كوريا الحديث عبر امداد كوريا
بالطاقه همم اليوم ميسون احنا في همم
في مرحله جديده همم الشركات الكوريه
الكبرى التي اللي ساهمت في بناء كوريا
المعاصره مثل السامسونج مثل هونداي تتطلع
اللي اقتناص فرص همم
فرص جديده للبناء في السعوديه مشاريع
الجيجا بروجيكت في نيوم في البحر الاحمر
في القديه همم كلها مشاريع مميزه وهذه
الشركات الضخمه اللي موجوده الان في كوريا
همم تطلع اللي ان تكون لها فرص هناك اليوم
كان في اجتماع همم لولي العهد السعودي مع
رؤساء تنفيذيين همم للشركات الكبيره هنا
في في كوريا وكان همم الحديث حسب ما تم
تسريبه الى الان همم كان الحديث حول
الجيجاكس في السعوديه
وما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه الشركات الكوريه
الكبرى
لهذه المشاريع
الملحقيه الثقافيه
في كوريا الجنوبيه ايضا ناشطه جدا وموضوع
اخر جدا مهمه في كوريا الجنوبيه وهو موضوع
الابتعاث
العديد من المبتعثين المتواجدين في
كوريا خاصه في مجال الطب
وحتى في الشهر الماضي ايضا احد الاطباء
السعوديين يعني نال جائزه
وايضا وصف بانه من ابرز الاطباء في اختصاص
صمامات القلب
هناك تبادل همم ثقافي تبادل ايضا همم
كما كنا ايضا شارك اقتصاديه كبيره وموضوع
هذا الابتعاد الى اي حد برايك ايضا موضوع
هذا الابتعاث قرب هذا التعاون وجعل
البلدين يعرفان اكثر عن ثقافات بعضهما
البعض
التبادل الثقافي مثل ما تحدث لك السفير
السعودي في لقاء الاجلتين معه قبل يومين
بين ال- همم الطلاب السعوديين او ما بين
السعوديين وهمم والكوريين في في تزايد
خلال السنوات همم الاخيره سواء عبر
التكنولوجيا اللي قاعد تدخل لك البيت
السعودي وهي تكنولوجيا جايه من من كوريا
عن طريق الموسيقى او عن طريق الثقافه
العربيه ايضا قربت هذه يعني كوريا
الجنوبيه من السعوديه ومن غيرها ايضا من
دول الشرق الاوسط
امام شعبين شعبين همم شاب شاب سواء في
كوريا او في السعوديه
في عندهم طموح كبير لصناعه الغد افضل
والقرار موجود من الجهات السياسيه في
البلدين
همم فاتوقع ان المستقبل ال- ال- العلاقه
والتعاون ما بين كوريا والسعوديه راح
يتطور اكثر في وقت هو مميز فيه جدا الان
عندما نتحدث عن هذه المشاريع الكبيره مثل
نيوم ذا لاين القديه هذه المشاريع هل
نتحدث اتدخلت هذه الشركات الكوريه عليها
تكون هي منافسه لشركه اخرى ام تستحوذ على
مثل هذه المشاريع همم
ميسون انا اليوم وانا اسمع عن الشركات
الكبيره سامسونج
والفرس اللي ممكن تحصلها في همم في
المشاريع الكبيره في السعوديه في يوم
اذكر صور انك تشوفها وانا صغير للمعدات
الامريكيه وهي جايه
المنطقه الشرقيه في السعوديه للتنقيب عن
عن النفط انا اشوف ان السعوديين راح
يكونون على موعد لدخول همم معدات واليات
كبيره همم ممكن تكون موجوده في نيوم او
ممكن تكون موجوده في البحر الاحمر لعمليات
الانشاء اللي راح تكون في في هذه المناطق
هي مرحله تحول تاريخيه تعيشها السعوديه
الان همم لتنويع مصادر داخلها والانتقال
من الاعتماد على النفط الى قطاعات همم
عقيل في هذين اليومين يعني من خلال
تغطياتنا لهذه الزياره همم ايضا تعرفنا
اكثر على الثقافه الكوريه وعلى همم ماذا
يمتلكون في هذه الدوله
انت اكثر من زياره طباعه
رائع
جميل الشعب محبه بكثير واجمل شيء ايه هو
هذا الاراده اللي همم جعلته ينجح الى هذا
الحد يعني كان عاملا واصبح الان يتزوق
صحيح في وقت قصير قصير جدا الان سنعود الى
زميلنا خالد لمتابعه الرابعه
ما لديك من اخبار خالد الجنوبيه
صحيح صحيح ههه
صحيح راح نكون ان شاء الله في في الرياض
في موسم الرياض خالد
نتابعك الجديد عن الفرق الكوريه اللي راح
تشارك طيب انا شاكر مقدم لكم تواجدكم
يعطيكم العافيه من
العاصمه الكوريه ميسون شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل السعوديه تحقق
المرتبه الثالثه عالميا في مؤشر نضج
الحكومه الرقميه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت مصادر الدبلوماسيه
للعربيه
حول دعوه ايران للتعاون بشكل عاجل مع
تحقيق وكاله الطاقه الذريه
امكانيه احاله ملف ايران الى مجلس الامن
في حال استمرارها بعد التعب
وعلى صعيد اخر اتهم وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه حسين الامير عبد اللهيان
اسرائيل والدول الغربيه بوضع مخططات
لتقسيم ايران وزير الخارجيه غرد عبر تويتر
الامنيه والاستخباراتيه تحاول تفكيك ايران
وتدميرها واكد ان ايران ليست ليبيا او
السودان انها لن تقبل بهذه المخططات
الايراني صالح حميد سيد صالح حياك الله
معي في نشره الرابعه اولا يعني حسب
متابعتك هل تعتقد بان هناك اليوم موقف
مختلف من قبل المجتمع الدولي
في اتخاذ قرارات لها صيغه اليه الزناد
بشكل اقوى على ايران اكثر من قبل
يعني في البدايه يجب ان نقول نعم الوضع
مختلف لانه سابقا كانت ايران تنتج اسلوب
المماطله لانها كانت واثقه من سياسه
التراضي والمهادنه سواء من قبل الاوروبيين
او اداره الرئيس الامريكي جوبادل الان وضع
مختلف تماما الاوضاع الملتهبه داخل ايران
والاحتجاجات المستمره التي همم تتحول الى
ثوره يوما بعد يوم القت بظلالها سواء على
الوضع الداخلي الايراني او على التعامل
على تعامل يعني المجتمع الدولي بشكل عام
مع ايران راينا صدور عده قرارات اماميه
كان اخرها البارحه من الجزء الثالث
المتحده بدون انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في
ايران الاداره الامريكيه تقول ان اولويتها
الان متابعه ما يجري داخل ايران همم ومن
احتجاجات الدول الاوروبيه ايضا لها موقف
مماثل اذا ما احيل همم اليوم او غدا اا
ملف ايران النووي الى مجلس الامن اييي
اعتقد ان هذا سيكون فصل جديد في التعامل
مع ايران لانه ايران الان تقوم بخطوات
خطيره جدا يعني الامر ليس فقط مبالغه
اعلاميه او تهويل سياسي ايران منذ اشهر
اكثر من سته اشهر ازالت الكاميرا تخصص
باليورانيوم بنسب 20% واحيانا 60% حسب
التقرير الوكاله بثمانيه عشر ضعف همم وفق
الاتفاق كانت هي تخصب يورانيوم يعني نسبته
لا تتجاوز ثلاثه فاصله 75% الان همم هناك
يعني اهدافه واضحه همم غير سلميه
وذات ابعاد عسكريه واضحه كما انها لا تكشف
عن المواقع التي اجرت اساسيه اليوم هل هي
متعلقه بموضوع الملف النووي الايراني
والتطورات بشكل اساسي ان الدول يعني ايه
بشكل اكبر بمواضع اخرى تتعلق بمثل ااا
تدفق المسيرات والصواريخ الى سوريا وهي
المشكله الاكبر التي تواجهها اوروبا حاليا
صحيح لكن
بكل الاحوال لا يمكن فصل الملفات عن بعضها
البعض لانه هذه سياسه هجوميه يتبعها
النظام الايراني في الداخل ينفق هذه
الاموال على التسليح وعلى النوبه وفي
الخارج يغذي الميليشيات ويصدر المسيرات
والصواريخ التي كانت تستهدف دول المنطقه
من خلال تزويد من مليشيات الحوثيين الى
حزب الله للحشد الشعبي والان ارسال صواريخ
والمسيرات همم في الحرب الاوكرانيه واصبح
واصبح الايرانيون طرفا في هذه الحرب من
خلال قتل الاوكرانيين همم لكن بالنسبه
للملف النووي الوضع الخطير هو انه هناك
ابعاد مشبوها يعني هناك ابحاث ذات بعد
عسكري يمكن يعني لايران من خلالها وفقا
للخبراء خلال اشهر ان تحصل على قنبله
نوويه وهذا النظام وسلوكه العدواني يثير
الكثير من الرب
هناك مواقف مختلفه من الغرب تجاه موضوع
التعاطيبي بضغط اكبر على ايران في في فتره
سابقه بالتالي اليوم هل يمكن ان يكون هناك
اجماع فعلي اليوم الى اي مدى هذا سيكون
مثمرا يعني اليه الزنا هل يمكن لها ان
تؤثر على ايقاف تدفق مسيرات والصواريخ
مثلا
ايضا الهدف اساسي لهذه الدول نحو روسيا او
تكون لها تاثير في اضعاف مثلا نظام في
مواجهه الاحتجاجات والمظاهرات التي تتصاعد
يوم بعدها
يعني الخطوه الخطوه نقل الملف ايران الى
مجلس سيكون لها بعدين بعد سياسي همم وبعد
عسكري يعني وبعد السياسي يتمثل في فرض
المزيد من العقوبات همم العوده الاليه
للعقوبات مثل تلك التي شلت النظام عام
2011 و2018
واضطر النظام همم
المرشد الايراني علي خامني ان يطلق ما
سماها المرونه البطوليه ويسمح بالمفاوضات
البعد الثاني هو الشق العسكري يمكن ان هذا
ما يخول المجتمع الدول تحت استخدام القوه
العسكريه تحت فصل
المتوقعه بالطبع ايران تعود على هذا تحسب
حسابا لكن اذا ما يعني وصلت فعلا ايران
الى الحافه اي حافه الوصول على ساحه
النووي من الممكن ان همم تقوم بعض الدول
مثل اسرائيل بخطوات كما قامت بتفجير يعني
فعلنا طنز همم ضرب بعض همم الاهداف همم
العسكريه والمواقع انه في جنوب طهران مثلا
همم
واعتقد ان هذا ما سيدفع المنطقه الى همم
نحو المزيد من سباق التسلح والمواجه
مباشره والمفتوحه بين ايران واسرائيل ايضا
الواضح كذلك ان هناك خشيه كبيره هذه المره
من قبل ايران في ردود الافعال الايرانيه
يعني خاصه يعني ما انه قبل قليل من موقف
لحسين امير عبد الله ومواقف اخرى ايضا من
مسؤولين ايرانيين قالوا بانهم سيردون بشكل
قرارات رادعه اكثر اذا ما بالفعل تم تبني
اي قرار او اي مشروع في مجلس الالام بدا
يمكن ان تقدم عليه يعني هذه المواقف
المتشدده من قبل مسؤولين تعني ان ايران
تريد ان تهرب الى الامام من ما يجري داخل
في الواقع تريد ان تصاعد هي دائما تحاول
همم يعني همم
همم ارجع ونسبه والصاق ما يحدث من مشاكل
لها في الداخل بسبب سوء الاداره بسبب
انفاق الاموال على مشروع التوسعي في
المنطقه الى مؤامرات خارجيه هذه المره قد
يعني تقوم ايضا همم تصعيد مماثل لكي تقول
انها تتعرض الى هجمه خارجيه وتبرر القمع
في الداخل خاصه وان المظاهرات والاحتجاجات
تتصاعد هي دخلت شهرها الثالث بشكل غير
مسبوق هناك اضرابات عامه هناك مواجهات
ليليه بين القوات الامن همم والناس العزل
وراينا يعني هروب كبير حتى لقوات الان في
الكثير من المدن الايرانيه المنتفظه اعتقد
ان احداث تكتيكات النظام هو همم تصدير هذه
الازمه الى الخارج من خلال القول ان طيران
تتعرض الى هجمه خارجيه الى ضغوط من قبل
الدول الغربيه ما هي الخيارات التي يمكن
ان تتخذ همم يعني همم تحدثت عن الداخل همم
القمع ربما هو الاسلوب المتبع او من قبل
النظام الايراني سواء من قبل الجيش ايش
النظام والحرس الثوري او غيره لكن ماذا عن
التعامل مع هذا الامر هذه الضغوط من ناحيه
تصدير المشكله ربما للخارج كيف ستتعامل مع
الموقف وهو النظام كان دائما يلعب على عمل
عامل القمع المباشر في الداخل بالقوه
الامنيه والقبضه الحديديه وفي الخارج كان
يعول على همم موقف المهادنه والتراضي الان
الوضع تغير الان النظام يخشى كثيرا ان
تعترف القوه الاوروبيه بالمعارضه او همم
قوه المجتمع المدني يعني راينا رئيس
الفرنسي استقبل الناشطات ايرانيات البيت
الابيض كذلك صحيح لم
يتجاوز هذا الدعم همم
همم نشط على المجتمع المدني الى الاحزاب
السياسيه لكن الان هناك دعم كبير الى ما
يقوم به الايراني هناك اعتراف وهناك ثقه
يعني دائما كان الايراني يخشون ان يتم
تدخل خارجي لصالح النظام كما حدث في
الانتفاضه الخضراء مثلا عام 2009 لكن هذه
المره الوضع مختلف تماما الايرانيون
يريدون من من المجتمع الدولي ان لا يعترف
بهذا النظام ويعترف بثوره في الدار شكرا
حميد الباحث العراق
ونذهب لاني لتايلاند وهذه الكلمه لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي في منتدى
مهم لاداره العلاقه بشكل مسؤول والتعامل
مع المنافسات
الموجوده وكذلك
ايجاد مجالات للتعاون خاصه
بالقضايا التي لا تؤثر فقط على شعب نبيل
على شعوب العالم وهذا متوقع منا وهو من
الامور التي سمعتها من دوله اخرى
وبعد الجماع في مجموعه العشرين
بامر برحب به ان نرى كل القيادات سويا وان
تكون هناك اداره للعلاقات بشكل مسؤول واجد
السبل للتعاون ال ال الجوله التي ساقوم
بها هذا في اوائل العام القادم هي
للمتابعه على تقويه العلاقات والتواصل بين
اعضاء الحلف حلفته
وايضا مناقشه قضايا عده بما فيها همم ايضا
همم تحدث عن الصين تحدث معهم همم حول
العلاقات
الاقتصاديه والعلاقات السياسيه والنجد سبل
للتعاون
في الصحه والمناخ
والاقتصادات
الجزئيه وكذلك هذا امر مهم ليس لشعوبنا بل
هو لشعوب العالم كامله
واتفقنا قبل ايام على اننا سنحدد
التوقيت وجدول الاعمال اللقاءات ايضا
سيحدث خلال فتره بسيطه اما
بالنسبه لليوم
تحدثنا عن
المعتقل في بورما بشكل ظالم
فاستفيرنا اااه التحضيه بفرصه للقاء بهلي
السعوديه المرتبه الثالثه عالميا بين 198
دوله في مؤشر الحكومه الرقميه الصادر عن
مجموعه البنك الدولي للعام الجديد 2022
يقيس المؤشر الصادر عن البنك الدولي 4
مجالات الرئيسيه شاملت كل من توفر الامر
الحكوميه الاساسيه تقديم الخدمات الحكوميه
الرقميه التفاعل مع المواطنين وتعزيز
ممكنات التحول الرقميه
محافظو هيئه الحكومه الرقميه المهندس احمد
السويانا كدنا تحقيق السعوديه المرتبه
الثالثه عالميا والاولى اقليميه في بيانات
مؤشر نضج الحكومه الرقميه ايات نظيره
مرحله نضج للخدمات الحكوميه المقدمه
للمواطنين والمقيمين
حققنا نتيجه تاريخيه بجهود الجهات
الحكوميه وبالدعم السقي واللامحدود من
القياده الرشيده انه تقدمنا اثنا عشر
مرتبه في مؤشر تطور الحكومه الالكترونيه
الصادر من منظمه الامم المتحده وحققنا
المرتبه 31 كانت هي افضل مرتبه حققتها
المملكه منذ 20 سنه ولكن اليوم يصدر مؤشر
اخر من مجموعه البنك الدولي وهو مؤشر نضج
الحكومه الرقميه وهذا المؤشر ولله الحمد
للمملكه حققت المرتبه الثالثه عالميا
والافضل العربيا وايضا في المنطقه وهذا
يؤكد على نضج الخدمات الحكوميه الرقميه
واحتمامها بالمواطنين والزوار وايضا
المقيمين وعائلاتهم
للاهتمام بيئه الاعمال وتقديمها بشكل
مثالي اليوم المملكه في هذا المؤشر مصنفه
من الدول المتقدمه جدا
وتعتبر من الدول المبتكره والمبدعه في
مجال التحول الرقمي والاعتماد على
التقنيات والتقنيات الناشئه تحديدا ايضا
من الرابعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل تدشينه
ملتقى الاستثمار في القصيم والمشاريع
التنمويه بقيمه تتجاوز مليارينها
الامير محمد بن سلمان يختتم زيارته الى
سوق 25 عقد استثماريا بنحو 30 مليار دولار
مصادر الدبلوماسيه تكشف للعربيه قرارا
لوكاله الطاقه ولم يحل حاله ايران مجلس
الامن
ملتقى الاستثمار في القصيم مئات والفرص
والمشاريع التنمويه بقيمه تتجاوز ريال
ضمن موسم الرياض الرابعه تتجول في مدينه
السعاده انشطه حركيه وتكنولوجيه للاطفال
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه انطلقت
اليوم في منطقه القصيم فعاليات ملتقى
الاستثمار بمشاركه عده جهات من القطاع
العام والخاص يستعرض الملتقى 150 فرصه
استثماريه بالمنطقه متاحه للاستثماري لدى
مختلف الجهات الحكوميه تترجم خارطه النمو
الاقتصادي
للمنطقه منطقه القصيم التنمويه واقتصاديا
واستعرضت وزاره البلديه والشؤون او وزاره
الشؤون البلديه خلال الملتقى اكثر من 600
فرصه استثماريه واربعه مشاريع سكنيه
بالشركه مع القطاع الخاص 146 مشروعا
تنمويه بقيمه تصل الى اكثر من مليارينها
من ملتقى الاستثمار في القصيم ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه سلطان السلمي حياك الله
سلطان حدثنا اكثر عن الملتقى وعن اهم
الفرص الاستثماريه التي تعرضها القصيم من
خلاله
اهلا بك خالد واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل يشكل ملتقى الاستثمار
بالقصيم حلقه ربط بين رواد الاعمال
والمستثمرين من الداخل والخارج وبين
القطاعات الحكوميه التي لها ارتباط مباشر
بالمستثمرين وحتى الراغبين بالدخول سوق
العمل المحلي لتحدث على وزارات واجهات
حكوميه عده بمقدمتها وزاره التجاره وزاره
الطاقه وزاره الاستثمار وزاره الصحه
وغيرها من الوزارات التي اليوم تشارك في
هذا الملتقى الذي بدا يوم امس سوف يستمر
لمده ثلاثه ايام نتحدث على ثمانيه مسارات
مهمه في قطاع السياحه في قطاع في قطاع
الخدمات اللوجستيه وقطع الاستثمار وغيرها
من القطاعات المهمه التي تدرج هنا او او
تم مناقشتها خلال هذه الفرص الاستثماريه
خلال 30 جلس عفوا 30 متحدث عبر سته جلسات
رئيسيه طوال هذا اليوم تفاصيل حول ابرز
الفرص التي المتاحه للمستثمرين في منطقه
القسيم من الداخل ينضم الى الاستاذ او
الدكتور
يوسف العريني المت- المشرفه العامله مركز
التنميه الاقتصادي باماره منطقه القصيم
بدايه ما الذي سوف يميز منطقه القصيم
لجدول المستثمرين بالمليارات هنا اليوم
شكرا لكم
الملتقى الاستثمار بالقصيم واحد مبادرات
سمو امير المنطقه
والقسيم تفخر بمزايا كثيره جدا هي اللي
جعلتها تكون مكان مناسب للاستثمار داخل
اهم المورد البشري والقوه الاقتصاديه
الموجوده بالمنطقه توسط المنطقه فهي وسط
المملكه بالنسبه للنقل وكامل للاستثمارات
اللي ممكن تكون فيها سهوله التحرك بين
المناطق المجاوره الربط بالمطار والقطار
والطرق السريعه في كل المناطق المملكه من
داخل القصيم طيب ماذا عن ابرز الفرص
الاستثماريه المتاحه اليوم في ملتقى
الاستثمار وتم مناقشتها اكثر من 100 فرصه
استثماريه متنوعه همم في حاله الفرصه فيها
الان مختلفه ما بين كبير ومتوسطه صغيره
كذلك يوجد عدد من الفرص الاستثماريه عند
وزاره اثمار سيتم على
تقترب وكذلك وزاره الصحه لدي استثمارات
كبيره جدا تخصيص ستكون من ضمن استثمارات
الوزاره التي تكون بالقصيم باذن الله
تعالى ماذا الوجود المستثمرين السعوديين
وكذلك المستشمل الاجنبيه او المستثمر
الاجنبي عفوا غرف المنطقه العموما غرفه
القصيم والعمل طبعا هذا مشترك بين امارات
المنطقه وامانه المنطقه وغرفه القصيم
وباقي الغرف فالقصيم ميزتها انها تعمل
مشتركه بين رجال الاعمال وكافه القطاعات
الحكوميه والخاصه فينا اعطاها نجاح باهر
جدا لدينا مستثمرين وصلوا اليوم من اوروبا
وكذلك من بعض الدول العربيه ومن داخل
مناطق المملكه عدد من رؤساء المملكه حضروا
وكلهم يرغبوا في الاستثمارات المتاحه في
القصيم ان شاء الله القطاعات التي يجب
يعني يجب النظر عليها واستثمار داخلها في
القصيم يعني نعتقد ان مثلا انقطاع التعديل
في القصيم اكثر من 390 من جنب متوفر في
القصيم 15 نوع من المعادن المتوفره كذلك
كل مجال الصحه المجال التعليم ايضا لدينا
مجالات كثيره جدا يعني القصيم ايضا منبع
لل- تنتج يوميا اكثر من 39 طالب متخرج من
الكليات القصيم الاهليه والخاصه تنتج
القصيم ايضا 822 طنور يوميا همم تنتج ايضا
اكثر من همم
مليون ونص رغيف باليوم تنتج مليون ونصف
عبوه مويه في اليوم تنتج مليون ونصف ايضا
بيضه في اليوم تنتج القصيم في اليوم مليون
دجاجه ايضا جاهزه للاكل ماذا عن ابرز
الاهداف والمخرجات المتوقعه من الملتقى
كنا حريصين حقيقتنا انه يكون التركيز في
القصيم على النياز النسبيه اللي تتميز
فيها القصيم وكذلك الميز التنافسيه
الموجوده في القصيم وركزنا على جذب
المستثمرين للفرس الاستثماريه المتاحه في
القصيم فالقصيم به استثماريه ناجحه بكل
المقاييس وعلى كل المستويات تتوفر فيها كل
انواع الاستثمارات
ويتوفر لدينا
جهات جهاز الى الشراكه مع مستثمرين من
خارج او داخل المملكه
يعني اخيرا ماذا عن المبادرات
القصيم فيها اكثر من 70 مبادره ثم امير
المنطقه الله يحفظه هذه احد مبادرات وهذه
مبادرات سمو الامير لكن يوجد مبادرات
كثيره جدا حتى في ال في الجهات الحكوميه
مثل ارامكو غير كلهم عارض مبادرات اليوم
كلها تصف في دعم رواد الاعمال شكرا لكم
شكرا لك انا معانا الدكتور يوسف العريني
المشرفه العام على مركز التنميه الاقتصادي
باماره منطقه القصيم نعم خالد شكرا جزيلا
لك سلطان السلمي من ملتقى الاستثمار في
القصيم
جبل الدقم هو اهم او احد اهم الاماكن
السياحيه في الجزائر جنوب غرب السعوديه
يتميز بوجود ضمن منطقه سياحيه تهاميه
وتحيط به مناطق زراعيه كبيره يمتاز الجبل
بجده سياح ومحبي رياضه التسلق والهيكنج
جبل الدقم الجبل الاشهر في محافظه العارضه
بجازان والمتميز بارتفاعه ووجوده على
منطقه زراعيه كثيفه ما جعله احد اهم
الاماكن السياحيه ما يميز الجبل عمره
الطويل الذي يزيد عن خمسه الاف عام
جبل الدقم عباره عن تشكيلات صخريه مسطحه
ضمن منطقه سهليه بالقرب من سد وادي جازان
ويسر ارتفاعه الى قرابه 150 مترا
جبل الدقم والمناطق المحيطه به تعد وجهه
لاهل المنطقه وزوارها عن جبل الدقم الكثير
من الاساطير لكنها لم تثبت باي دراسات او
ابحاث علميه موثقه من العارضه اسامه
القاسم العربيه ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياضه
وتحديدا في وانتر وندرلاند وضيفه للمنطقه
ملاهي الجديده
في عاليات جديده تشهدها مناطق موسم الرياض
في نسخته الثالثه منها مدينه السعاده او
كما تعرف بها بكم التي تتوسط منطقه وينتر
وندر لاند وهي مدينه مخصصه للاطفال
لممارسه الانشطه الحركيه والتكنولوجيا
[موسيقى]
واقف صامتا
[تصفيق]
اه انت محدث صحيح نعم لان من سمات المحقق
ان يهدد شرابها حسنا نو نو نو نو
هذا المكان المخصص للاطفال يساعدهم على
تنميه مهاراتهم الحركيه والدهنيه بانشطته
المتنوعه ما بين اللعب الكره والطبخ وما
بين الرسمي والتلوين
[موسيقى]
فتحت النافذه شتاء شتاء شتاء التجارب
العلميه البسيطه كانت حاضره لتثقيف
الاطفال في مجال العلوم المرحه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الى جانب التسلق للوصول الى القمه ليشعر
الاطفال بالانجاز
[موسيقى]
من الرياض شهد متروك
القمر يختفي ليله واحده اذا كان الشهر
هاتي اي 29 يوما ويختفي ليلتين اذا كان
الشهر وافي اي 30 يوم تقويم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ليله واحد يا غاب الهلال معايده مغيب
الشمس ليله الاثنين يا غاب الهلال بينما
يغيب الشمس ومغيب الشفق الاحمر ليله
الثلاثاء يغاب الهلال مع مغيب الشفق
الاحمر وقت العشاء وفي منتصف الشهر يشرق
البدر مع مغيب الشمس وعن طريق قمه الابداع
يعرف العامه تمامه الشهري من نقصانه فاذا
كانت قمه التبذر يوم 14 قال العامه ترى
الشهر 29 يوما واذا كانت القمه يوم 15 قال
العامه ترى الشهر 30 يوما الشهور الهجريه
شهور كونيه وليست اصطلاحيه كحال الشهور
الميلاديه ف تعتمد على ظاهره كونيه مشاهده
بالعين المجرده فبدايتها ونهايتها تعتمد
على رؤيه الهلال ومنازل القمر يعرف العامه
اليوم من الشهر رايت الهلال ووجه الحبيب
فكان هلالين عند النظر فلم ادري من حيرتي
منهما هلال الدجى من هلال البشر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والقمر يشاهدوا بالعين المجرده 28 يوما
ولهذا منازل القمر 28 منزله والمنازل هي
المحطات التي يستريح بها القمر في كل ليله
اثناء رحلته الشهريه حول الارض فاذا كان
شهر حافي 29 يوما فانه يستر ان يختفي ليله
واحده واذا كان شهر وافي 30 يوما فانه
يستر
لليتين وقال اصيحاب الفرار او الردى
فقلتهما امراني احلاهما مر سيذكروني قومي
اذا جد جدهم وفي الليله الظلماء
يفتقد البدر
[موسيقى]
ختم الرابعه بابرز العناوين
الامير محمد بن سلمان يختتم زيارته الى
العاصمه الكوريه سول خمسه وعشرون عقدا
استثماريا بنحو 30 مليار دولار
مصادر الدبلوماسيه تكشفه للعربيه
قرارا لوكاله الطاقه
باحاله ايران لمجلس الامن الدولي
تسجيل ملتقى الاستثمار في القصيم مئات
الفرص والمشاريع التنمويه بقيمه تتجاوز
مليار ريال
وضمن موسم الرياضه الرابعه تتجول في مدينه
السعاده انشطه حركيه وتكنولوجيه للاطفال
[موسيقى]